so this weekend Fox News was completely
off the deep end in a hilarious amalgam
of calculated cancel culture complaints
and possibly even drunken hosts again
yes I'm talking about Janine Pirro so
let's take a quick tour through all of
it now I I have to tell you I expected
right-wing media to get really really
nuts when Donald Trump left and there
were a lot of different reasons for that
some of them were political some of them
were Financial some of them were the
personal sort of uh uh uh goals of
individuals wanting to maintain
proximity to power in different ways or
whatever I didn't think it would be this
cartoonish so first of all Judge Jeanine
Pirro she's a former judge and host on
Fox News she hosted Republican senator
Rand Paul who at this point is comically
not credible as an individual and Rand
Paul asserted without any evidence you
know because of Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden's alleged connections to China if
China nuked the United States
Joe Biden might not even respond
what
Joe Biden would do nothing if the U.S
was nuked what are you talking about
Rand yes that's what he's saying take a
look real question there has been
question also of Hunter bidens and the
Biden Family Ties to Chinese business
and there may be something that they
consider that they have an in with the
bidens that will cause them uh not to
respond to any kind of nuclear
aggression I hope not now of course that
claim was was made as you can probably
tell completely without any evidence
whatsoever the idea that Biden would do
nothing if China nuked the United States
is so absurd as a thing for a sitting
Senator to say that the discussion we
should be having is whether Rand Paul
should or can be expelled from the
Senate rather than whether there's any
Merit to what he's saying and then a
seemingly drunk again I mean this is not
the first time this has happened
um an unbalanced Judge Jeanine Pirro
talks about cancel culture but fails to
mention her own network canceled
Lou Dobbs the day before take a look
you're the weak ones you're the
Unfaithful ones you don't deserve a job
with three months off so an entire
segment about they'll never cancel me
and canceling this and canceling that
shutting down the other thing not a
single mention of Lou Dobbs being
canceled by Fox News that's really the
only prominent Republican cancellation I
can think of recently Josh Hawley not
getting to do a book with a private
company that's not a cancellation that's
called business
um but no mention of the Lou Dobbs
cancellation then on another show on
this same Saturday night
Jesse Waters who's another host at Fox
News brings in Dog the Bounty Hunter for
political analysis about a supposed
crime wave being driven by Joe Biden
even though Biden's done nothing of the
sort Now dog is not totally coherent
here but I have to give dog credit he
didn't feed into the framing of the
segment as much as I would have expected
him to and he actually said let's see
what Joe Biden does I hope Joe Biden
does well you'll hear a lot of very
strange noises in the background dog
wearing sunglasses I mean it's all very
weird but dog doesn't doesn't jump in
full uh head first the way I thought he
was going to for more on this Dog the
Bounty Hunter Dwayne dog Chapman all
right do you agree with my assessment
those four things that are driving the
crime wave and what are we gonna do
about it
foreign
yes kind of I agree I just don't think
there's that much Gloom of Doom but you
know I'd like to ever everyone is
waiting to see what President Biden's uh
crime plan is
I we hope that he's solid on crime and
not that he's uh soft on it we want him
of course to back the blue we want
officers protected we want our civil
rights protected and I you know we're
going into I'm uh not I'm an optimist so
I'm excited about going into the new uh
you know the new realm for America right
now
I want to see what President Biden has
got for for crime and hoping that the
prosecutors are not all soft on crime
and
let's see what he's got right we want
Joe Biden to be solid and not soft but
okay I mean thanks dog at least he
didn't come in and just directly slander
Biden the way Jesse Waters wanted him to
do I'm guessing that's not the analysis
Jesse Waters was hoping for Jesse Waters
also did an entire segment on the
supposed canceling of conservatives so
Janine Pirro did a defiant segment about
cancellation Jesse Waters did a segment
about cancellation of conservatives lo
and behold Jesse also didn't mention
that Lou Dobbs just 24 hours earlier was
canceled by Jesse's own network that
apparently was not an important data
point in the cancellation of
conservatives to make the segment then
yesterday morning
Republican Senator Ron Johnson goes on
uh Maria bartiromo's show and uh makes
all sorts of wacky speculation is this
impeachment all about we now know that
the 45 Republican Senators believe it's
unconstitutional is this another
diversion operations this meant to
deflect uh away from potentially what
what the speaker knew and when she knew
it I don't know but I'm suspicious yeah
so speculation completely without any
evidence there and here's a bonus
segment this is Ron Johnson referring to
this is this is I've never heard this
before he referred to my birth country
of Argentina
as Argentina I I don't know why I
absolutely love this bonus clip for you
from yesterday morning a study coming
just the day before out of Argentina so
uh
as you can see a lot of chaos coming out
of Argentina
affecting the United States right now
and I will be calling my relatives to
figure out what exactly is happening
down there I need to know really strange
stuff happening on Fox News and Fox News
is in this interesting little place
where they are trying to figure out
how do we what what are we there's
almost like an identity crisis on Fox
news on the One Hand by acknowledging
that Joe Biden won we lost a bunch of
our audience to Fox to a Newsmax and oan
on the other hand if we go crazy or
right it's hard to go crazy or right
without getting into the types of
conspiracy theories that get you sued uh
like about Dominion voting machines
smartmatic or whatever at the same time
if we don't go right we might keep
losing audience it's not an enviable
position for me to be where Fox News is
right now but that's partially because
my morality would never let me work at
Fox News in the first place so I'm
probably not the right person to be
commenting but the next few months are
going to be very interesting to watch
the Dynamics of right-wing media and you
know what there's a excellent excellent
book
it's I don't even know if this book is
in print still I was able to get a copy
when I taught that class uh uh that when
I taught a college class about media
literacy and other things I got a copy
of this book called waves of rancor and
is it ranker or Rancor I never knew how
to say that word in any case the book is
basically about the history of
right-wing media and it goes back to
talking about you know father Coughlin
and how a lot of right-wing radio
started with a religious orientation and
although it's very very interesting and
there are sort of like these main eras
that are of significant change to
right-wing media and how the right has
used various types of Airwaves and
methods of communication for advancing
their agenda we may be in a realignment
right now and the realignment is a
combination of things it's the rift in
the Republican Party between trumpism
and non-trumpism affecting how these
different media Outlets relate to each
other and to the real world uh combined
with the actual repercussions that some
are experiencing for violating terms and
conditions on a variety of different
platforms so we could be
I I don't know what the next six months
will bring I do think part of it will
will depend on whether Donald Trump
launches this third party
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit more uh later on in the
program